SPEAKER: Police in
Russia recently pulled
over a hearse for speeding and
made an unexpected discovery--
$200,000 worth of contraband
hidden in the trunk.
And also the coffin.
The funny thing about
the accidental cost
is what was seized.
It wasn't drugs.
It wasn't weapons.
It was caviar.
$200,000 worth of
illegal caviar.
This report made
the rounds largely
on the strength of its
corkiness but it's actually
a small piece of a much larger,
ongoing story-- the story
of the illegal wildlife trade.
That term covers a lot.
Logging of exotic woods,
endangered animals
sold as pets, and
all sorts of wildlife
harvested for traditional
medicines and foods--
like caviar.
It's a broad term but it
adds up to big business.
In terms of money earned
for black marketers,
the wildlife trade is up there
with the drug and weapons
trades.
Smuggling fish or
plants or exotic pets
is a classic high risk,
high margin outfit.
In a lot of ways--
in fact-- it operates
a lot like the drug trade.
There are petty, small time
dealers-- in South Africa,
for example, chameleons
are caught illegally
and sold as pets on
the side of the road.
And then there's the big time.
Tiger skins reportedly go for
100 of thousands of dollars
a piece.
And profits like
that have attracted
the attention of
drug cartels looking
to diversify their businesses.
In other words, the
drug and wildlife trades
are similar enough that they
are actually starting to merge.
For the most part,
wildlife smuggling
is something that
individual countries
have to manage themselves.
The United Nations
did create a treaty
known as CITES, which lists
specific species under threat
of trafficking.
And recommends enforcement
policies to member countries.
And the vast majority
of world governments
have signed on to that treaty.
But CITES itself has almost
no enforcement power.
So like the UN, it's often
accused of impotence.
Meanwhile in all those
CITES member countries,
authorities are left to
their games of whack-a-mole
with wildlife smugglers.
That accidental caviar
bust is just one example
but it's actually
a pretty dire one.
Caviar traditionally
comes from sturgeon
in the Caspian and Black Seas.
Beluga sturgeon-- the largest
species in the family--
produce the most prized caviar.
And because of that they're
critically endangered.
In the 1990s and 2000s, beluga
experienced and 90% drop
in population.
In response, the US has
banned imports of it
and Russia has greatly
restricted beluga harvests.
The root of the problem
is that eating caviar
is celebrated in Russia.
That wasn't always the case.
Back in the 13th century, it
was considered peasant food.
But now caviar's popularity
is wrapped up in status.
And scarcity only inflames
it's exotic appeal.
So what can be done about
demand for illegal caviar.
Or for tiger skins or
chameleons for that matter.
Well one thing to do
at least, is make sure
that demand isn't meant.
Russian authorities are
taking this to heart
and doing with
seized caviar what
they'd be doing with seized
drugs-- they're destroying it.
Our profiting from-- and
disrupting of-- the environment
is not limited to wildlife.
Here's what happens when
natural resources are over
exploited as well.
This is a satellite image of
Padang, Indonesia in 2004.
This is that same place in 2008.
What happened in
between those two photos
wasn't an earthquake
or a typhoon,
it was one of the most
mysterious natural disasters
in memory.
And as always, don't forget
to subscribe to our channel.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]